more good couldn't go much further back
without opening the garage so I've been
dealing with this flat
tire for too long and um took my own
advice got some flat out so we showed
the uh the multi-seal version this is
like the small little gallons for
smaller tires but um multi-seal we had
Rick out about a year ago I guess it was
and he brought a whole test tire that he
takes to all of his shows and uh just
traveling around the country and doing
things with and it's just mounted to
like a receiver on the back of his on
the back of his truck and he takes like
a railroad spike or something a big old
Spike and just hammers it in the tire
like he's got hundreds and hundreds of
punctures in there and it just doesn't
leak it holds air it's just crazy and so
we finally got some of this stuff I need
to use it I've actually had my my arrows
out here just refilling it on the random
times that I I come use it and just fill
it back up and then it goes flat by the
next day every time so we're going to do
something about that today I Boston flat
out you can save 5% with code GWT on
that we'll put a link to their website
um comes with the stuff you need to do
and
basically if you get a lot of flat tires
like I do I should put this in every
single thing machine that I have I just
haven't
yet they've got a version on the
multi-seal website that actually mixes
with liquid Ballance like rard as well
so you can put it in an air fill Tire or
with a liquid fil
Tire pretty cool
stuff but I sick and tired of dealing
with this
flat so
hopefully this takes care of
it comes with everything you see here
you can buy it in different sizes for
different
tires this I think would fill if I
remember right would fill all four of
these tires on this uh
UTV if I filled all four but right now
we're going to do one and then um I'll
feel the paint again next time I get a
flat although we've been using that mini
dump primarily so what I'm doing well
let me tell you the instructions there
only five steps I think it was rotate
the tire so the valve stem is near the
top that's what we just got done doing
remove the valve core with the tool
provided and allow the tire to deflate
fully I think we're already at that
point but we'll we got to get the valve
core out of there so we can fill it up
then you attach this um pump fill it up
remove the hose replace the valve core
inflate to the recommended pressure and
re re uh re put the the
valve cap back on let me put that
somewhere I'm not going to lose
it it just has little grooves it's got
two sizes or two add two sizes and two
sides with a Groove in
there just just put the right one in
there a little bit of air but not much
left okay so that's our valve
core all right don't want to lose that
we'll put that in the same bag put our
tool back in
there put that on there I don't think we
need that though do
we I'll leave it down there sure why
not
there put that in
there okay so it says um one pump equals
o and in a a tire 27 in are smaller use
oz I guess I should double check that I
think I did before but I should double
check cuz 32 o 64 then double 128 I feel
like that's what it was going to be for
this this whole thing so anyway um 1 o
per stroke so 32
Strokes for 32
ounces the difference between flat out
and the competition up to a/ in seals
punctures up to a/ in compared to a/ qu
inch from the competition single
treatment works for 10 plus years versus
up to a couple years clean up stays
liquid easy clean up with water versus
latex or adhesive base becomes a sticky
mess so it's got some advantages there
let's do
it so I got to put this on here like
this and it's not going to spill all out
I guess this fits right on doesn't
it let's get that right on there all the
way that's as far as that can go
huh make sure that that sound there that
part already came on you ready see if
this works watch it fill up the
tube oh we got to wait I'm not going to
count so it's not there it's almost
there I'll count okay so there it's
there now one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 that's 20 wow it
does see I mean that's just 1 o per pump
huh 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31
okay so I got to take that out and then
replace the valve
core here can you can you show them that
see how that that uh the end is you know
it's not round so this can fit right
around there you see how that works so I
can grab
it
spin is that how I
uh that must be the end that went in
though oh yeah okay that goes this part
goes this part goes all the way into the
tire on the
inside and then I'm just fitting those
RS right in
there
okay is this going to make a big
mess not a big mess that's
nice
okay get this on
here
see if we can get that to twist back
in okay so far this has been pretty
easy okay that's on there nice and
tight put my oh we don't want to put the
cap on yet um next up we got a filler
full of
air
okay well that's it okay so this part's
the easy part right I'll know by this
time tomorrow I'd know when I wake up
tomorrow if it actually works or not it
didn't say anything about driving around
like to you know like get it
to fill out or anything like that which
I still feel like I might do that
anyways just because it seems like it
would make sense even if it even if they
don't talk about it the other thing I
don't know about is we did add 32 liquid
ounces in there so that is more weight
that's in this side versus the other
side now almost feel like it would be a
smart move to put it in the other side
so it's balanced out maybe that only
matters at higher speed applications I'm
not sure cuz this is I think they have
low speed and high speed applications
you'll see on their website um it'll
it'll go through all that so we don't
sell this stuff but you can go to uh the
Flatout website and the multi-seal
website and and get a pump that's super
handy like really that wasn't very hard
so as long as this works which we'll
find out here um because otherwise it'll
be flat it fixes most types of punctures
right I mean I don't know what type of
issue I have that's leaking out right
now there are certain things that it I
think it doesn't fix but it fix fixes
most things so uh we're we're going to
see if it works for this one and um
fingers crossed we'll find out soon so
that's what I've got for you today this
is one of those things you want to do as
a preventative measure we're doing this
as a what's the opposite of preventative
postventa
measure and
uh yeah I need to order more of it so I
can put in my tractors too because I'm
sure I'm going to get flats and I'm sure
I'm going to be in the same position
saying the same thing at some point in
the future doing this after the fact now
we don't sell this stuff but we do sell
tract and tractor attachments so if
you're in the market for a new tractor
or a tractor attachment for the front
end loader or a three-point hitch we'd
love to earn your business if you're not
sure what to get what size you need what
hookup you need well just send us an
email and give us your tractor making
your model we'll get you fixed up we'll
get you squared away with the right
thing to fit your machine and we sell
and ship Nationwide that's what we do we
have a big Warehouse we sell and ship
all over the country every day of the
week so go to goodworkstractors docomo
have to offer I want to thank you for
taking time out of your day to stop by
and until next time stay safe we'll see
you soon
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are the next day full of air
what do you know it actually worked
that's pretty nice here's the other Tire
I didn't screw this one up
either we flattened it down filled it up
put air back in it and it's holding
there too so problem solv this stuff
works I am happy to say don't know if it
fixes every single problem out there but
it worked this time and it's supposed to
work for most of them